Italian food is better than Jewish
correct that's actually really funny
like who's that guy that Sebastian
manager something like that he's like
you ever hear someone be like I have a
hankering for a gefilte fish no I don't
know let's go the Jewish trust hey
everybody happy Monday it is the 18th we
are doing something we have not done in
a very long time very long time very
long
what is this a fan mail mailbag the
mailbag episode we're just responding to
question we're doing we haven't really
done this Josh and I were laughing
because when we used to do this back at
like episode 10 mark page it and see how
count with send in their questions and
we go oh man I hope we have more than
just these two fast so when Josh tweeted
and put the Instagram up by the way a
lot of people were DMing me because they
thought I put it up and I was like no no
I started laughing because the DM inbox
blew up I showed it to e now my
girlfriend she was dying this is your
this is your show you know it's my show
you've collected all that yeah it was
amazing to see how many people scented
questions because like it's not money we
got hundreds hundreds and that's not a
joke like an episode ten Seahawk scout
and Mark Vasia were the only two people
that sent in questions on like eight
questions yes he would send eight
questions himself and then sometimes I
would read all eight and just say mark
Beijing or we would just make up names
send in a question okay good I think
Seahawk scouts doing his own podcast oh
you've been on it yeah I remember you
were supposed to go on it I don't know
that you do a lot so I got I got snacks
cuz this is because that's what I wanted
to do I want to listen to you chew into
the mic why we answer these this it's
almost as good as you during an
interview going
it's incredible okay I'm sorry I upset
face is a little purple right now
because I'd never heard it I need to
hear that actually okay so here's how
the mailbags gonna go so I've taken all
the questions I've organized them into
five categories which are gonna spend a
completely arbitrary amount of time on
depending upon how I feel the category
is going would you say we have a
plethora we do have a plethora of
questions would you say we have a corpse
of questions they have a good core Co re
of questions I'm gonna say right now to
everyone out there we're not gonna get
to all the questions so if we don't get
to yours we'll try and get to yours next
time and maybe we'll bring this back and
make it a regular staple if people like
it yeah all right so here the five
categories so first one back to where it
all began we had a lot of people that
came in and asked about the history of
the podcast what the hell the three of
us do all week so we'll do that first
second one is going to be inside the NFL
so that's going to be our football
questions third category is going to be
legs and ass that's gonna be our player
body questions portion of the show huh a
fair amount yeah we don't have a ton of
them but a good amount okay fourth
category I'm calling free-for-all a ton
of just ridiculous questions of like hey
can you ask Sims this can you ask left
go that so that'll be our free-for-all
and then the fifth category is gonna be
lightning round so that's gonna be are
you looking at Odell right now needs to
stay in here he's part of the studio
from now makes me happy okay fifth round
is gonna be the lightning round which is
basically we had a million questions of
like what do you think of the Seahawks
second area what do you think of the
Bucks D line so we're just gonna go
through all those back-and-forth you
guys will need to get to answer the
question all right so first question in
the first category here back to where it
all began Alex Osborn at Spanish Alex 85
and Kane 143 they had a similar question
how did all three of you get involved
with bleacher report and whose idea was
it to come up with the Sims and left go
podcast you want to start there left go
how you got here so I think I was first
and then Sims came about three months
after me I guess and that story has been
retold that you came to the party and I
approached you and I said hey I hear
you're a diva and so we hit it off me
and Sims were doing about 20 to 30
videos a day and we would go in the
office and we would argue when we'd talk
and we'd watch film
anything Josh walked in one day and said
you guys need to do a podcast yes and I
think Sims and I had talked about doing
it but I didn't know what to do and Sims
sure as hell didn't know what to do no
way Josh kind of took it over what
sounded miserable to me actually when he
said it I was like that's horrible I
didn't sign up for that no I'm pretty
sure you said that for about the first
hundred episodes is that this is
horrible isn't talking the podcast I was
gonna say I'm not gonna be the first
person to curse on this episode so you
used to say the effing podcast yeah
where were you before you got to
Bleacher well I was I had realized that
okay I did not want to work through the
New England Patriots or be a coach
anymore I know I wanted to get into the
media business I went to fs1 for a year
and did some college football games and
stuff like that
oddly enough I mean I knew about
bleacher report it wasn't something I
went on my agent approached me and he
said you know I got this like weird
offer from this bleacher report you know
they're kind of on the rise and it was a
great report
I've been I've been hearing more about
them I was like III hear you I was like
he goes I think it's really gonna fit
you you know they're looking for
somebody young and opinionated and kind
of like they need somebody to be the GM
further for bleacher report football and
I was like okay it sounds cool I came
and met people assault left go at that
super was a Super Bowl party I think it
was a super sight that it was and I
thought wow this is a pretty cool place
the people work here pretty cool and
then before you know it I was signed up
we were doing videos and yeah you you
approached about the podcast all right
and then I'll just say real quick I was
a production assistant at the ACC
digital network down in Charlotte North
Carolina got connected with my guy over
here to the left Adam left go yeah and
he was able to hook me up with an
interview and I came into bleacher
report as an associate producer about
four five months after you guys did and
he hooked you up do it was that the the
Jewish grandmother connection was our
Jewish what was my old boss's Jewish
grandmother who knew your grandmother
something like some weird connection to
Philadelphia was deeply personal off the
bat here was also I worked in Kentucky
as a sports anchor and a news reporter
in Nebraska that's what I did before
this next question at optimist Squatch
on Instagram who you guys are all
football all the time
are your guilty pleasures when you
aren't working too long of showers I am
an environmentalist I take showers too
long I love how long we talk man I take
about three showers a day first of all
one I think your OCD so are you someone
that like washes the same armpit
multiple of the shower man that's my
pleasure I feel guilty no and I really
have been asking for one because I other
houses I've lived in in my years past
I've brought like seats into the shower
and be like yeah I need something there
the shower it is not like the shower at
this time here because I sweat non-stop
right you're just weird and I don't feel
clean in here yes I can't go in then I
can't go to bed without taking a shower
before showers a day how long is each
one I would say the morning one semi
quick like five six minutes and then I
might get home from work or if I had
worked out and didn't have work then
that one can be a good 10 to 12 minutes
then I just avoid your family no no
you're like my kids are asleep or
they're at school and I take that midday
shower but yeah that's bad cuz I'm
wasting water that's right that's one of
my guilty pleasures laughs guy ultimate
guilty pleasure is biscuits I'm not
kidding I eat like three biscuits a week
when I go to a new city I type in best
biscuits and just see where I go to
those restaurants because I think that
there's nothing better in the world than
a good biscuit I also share your first
passion first a diverse fashion sativas
I don't know if Josh is gonna keep all
that in there you better look like a
total biscuit guy you getting fatter
yeah it's been a long time since use
that one that's probably one of mine and
then guilty pleasures I don't really
watch anything stupid or you know watch
America's Got Talent survivor
no I mean it's television
porn porn would be my other other guilty
pleasure but you're just killing me here
all right next question next question
here a dot height 6,000 what was your
opinion of the guys on the leba [ __ ]
show how were they off the radio
anything that you found surprising you
go first because you had the longest
relationship with them
okay I think was texting with Alison
today the thing that I realized the leba
tarde guys that I loved so much whether
it was dance to gods Alison any of the
guys behind the glass I felt like they
were like bleacher report really that's
where I love them it was very
open-minded just good-hearted people
that wanted to have some fun creative
conversations the first things right
super supportive I mean I just can't get
over how supportive stugots and Dan were
towards both of us really and just like
admiring what we do and how we're coming
up in the world and whatever it may be I
think the thing I was shocked by the
most about going there is first of all
how small was it looks on TV but just a
what a well-oiled machine they are with
the guys that are on the mic and then
the guys behind the glass I think I'm
constantly amazed Studios and this is a
note to everyone are always smaller than
you think
anywhere you go it's always going to be
smaller than you think but there there's
just such a heartbeat and you don't
realize how much the guys behind the
glass are doing for Labbit Arden's to
guts like the whole shipping container
is like a unit and they really love each
other and you could tell that Leba
tardes the kind of guy that if you
respect him they'll bend over backwards
for you like letting us in their room
and like sending us things and like that
that mug like they worked on that for a
long time amazing yeah just I've been
disappointed by so many people in this
industry and it's rare when I'm not only
like pleased but I'm like overwhelmed
that you exceed expectations and they
actually did it was the first time it's
ever happened yeah there's just good
freaking people that exactly right yeah
all right we're moving on to inside the
NFL first question in our non team
specific football section of this
podcast Sean O'Shay at Sean likes bacon
in regards to Julian Edelman if you were
told a substance could help you recover
from a terrible injury and you were
worried that without it you may never
have the strength and speed that made
you special is taking a 4-week hit worth
it is a four week suspension a
worthwhile investment for weeks that's
something that follows you the rest of
your life you know because now when you
when you type in Edelman step
Royce is gonna come up yeah when you go
to his Wikipedia page there's gonna be a
whole thing about scandal I know I don't
think it's for I don't think we'd ever
look at Melky Cabrera and be like that's
just a 50-game no that's a lifetime
stain but yeah I think it depends where
you are it's a great question it I mean
I understand I'm older and I need to
keep going I don't know it depends about
your concept of legacy like Simms
believes in purity and legacy I am kind
of like we're on this time for a good
time not a long time right so I'm not
saying I'm not okay with steroids but I
know you're really really it's an
asterisk next to his name forever it'll
always make me question what he did I
understand what the person's saying
there and and and I think like to
justify what he's saying with the
question I think there's a number of ex
players and people who would go well
damn I don't know I'm not so sure you
know like my dad my I've heard my dad
make these comments I don't think he's
gonna be mad that I said this but I've
heard him say well I don't know if there
was HGH in around Laura I'm not sure I
wouldn't have taken it you know like and
I know he's like serious and half
serious but I I understand because it is
your body and you want it to become
healthy and it's your lifeline and what
you're making money for and I understand
that question because okay I can get
back out there and get a hundred percent
if I take these supplements but no I
would never do that I had a chance to do
that right I mean I did and I went up to
Canada people accused me of going to see
a guy who took who got caught with HGH
in his car and this doctor Galya and I
will stick up up for him from the day I
die but to me it's it's it's not worth
it at the end of the day just because of
the personal thing that's what would
bother me going home to my family seeing
young kids whatever it may be that's
where I would really hurt me I guess I
answered that right now ya know I think
along with that too it's but that's what
people are coming to you the question
that's what it's coming down to is
people are going that's what I think a
lot of these players do like a Melky
Cabrera or a Julian Edelman
oh I'm hurt or man if I take this I
could get a longer term extend contract
extension so there and then also stop
right and agree they're selling their
soul to the devil for it and there's
going to be guys always out there that
are willing to do
that I just I think of it like the way I
think about driving on the highway
there's a lot of people that want to get
to their destination five minutes faster
for me the fear of looking in the
rearview mirror and seeing those cop
lights is the reason I go on cruise
control that's a lot of those guys are
like no I'm gonna go 90 and I'm gonna
get there and it's like for what man
yeah like just the fear of always like
I'm sure whenever someone came around
talking about steroids Julian was like
oh [ __ ] yeah I would never do it right
right right
at James McKeen 12 next question here
with Zack Martin and Richburg contracts
on the offensive line this year do you
think teams are now willing to spend
more on good protection than on elite
running backs like levy on bail a system
that makes the offensive linemen
Superstars and the running back position
less elite and more plug-and-play I
don't think the running back has ever
been elite I think it's been plug and
play now for a while I think if there's
going to be a different trend it's the
fact now that we're not going to get
these guard tackle guys trying to play
tackle in the NFL and not being good at
it
I think the guard position is now all of
a sudden valued I'm waiting for the
center position to get the respect the
salary wise yeah like all I ever hear
about is how important the quarterbacks
in a relationship is but with everyone's
starting to put pass rushers as interior
defensive lineman on third down the
guard has become just as important as
the tackle and now the salaries are
getting there that trend I would I'm
interested to see we talk about this all
the time yeah if offensive linemen can
start getting paid considerably more
than defensive linemen yeah when we
start getting those defensive linemen
athletes to start playing offensive line
right but it's a lot more fun to hit
people than get hit yeah it is and then
you don't have to think as much in the
defensive side of the ball either so you
can just play you don't have to worry
about all these rules and communication
all the time so I think that's where it
is I do think first of all let's just
think about the final four this year in
football all had good center play right
so that's one thing like I do think the
smart teams in football have realized
that's a very important position with
this day and age defense a tackle and
how versatile they are I think also the
other thing too the value is gonna
continue to go up on these guys why why
is the value gonna go up Josh well it
always goes up but there's one reason
that we talk about a lot of the times
why the value is going to go up on the
good ones because the quarterbacks
well offensive line pipeline is so
exactly that's really where it is to
where the good ones stand out above the
rest because the other guys are from the
big 12 conference and they ran four run
plays in four years in college football
to where now it's like damn you know
Zack Martin he's done all these pro
things in college and it's working in
the NFL and I think there is gonna
continue to be more value there and I
don't think the running back market is
gonna change a whole lot next question
here at Chris Dodd Smith 21 us n did you
have something else to say like oh no I
was just staring
what could you like what up to it
alright Chris Smith 21 us n what are
your favorite offense versus defense
matchups in the NFL pull up the teams
pull up the teams yes regardless of if
the teams are good just offense versus
defense best to watch on TV and scout
okay and we're saying we'd like to see
these against each other or justice in
general well Jackson's defense is
already there my defense that's the one
I want to see so who do you want to see
Ramsey up against Ramsey Brown Ramsey
Julio Ramsey Odell Ramsey Tyree kill
yeah I mean though Yeah right those are
kind of the team's I was looking at I
also look at teams like New Orleans and
things like that but Drew Brees its Sean
Payton in the style of that play they
play to where I go that could be a fun
matchup because the Saints are a little
more renegade than I think people
realize they talk trash a little more I
have a physical style play they have
that awesome offensive line they create
a passing schemes to go along with it
I'm excited to watch - Shawn Watson
versus that defense DeSean works for
Jacksonville you're Sean versus Jackson
yeah alright so are we picking an
offense or just the play offense in a
defense okay yeah I'm gonna go I would
go I would want to see Jacksonville
I think first the New Orleans Saints I
don't know why I just want to see Sean
Payton have to deal with that group drew
Brees have to deal with that group I
want to see Jacksonville have to go out
to style Jacksonville right I want to
see them enough to go out the run game I
just feel like that's an offense that's
not necessarily ultra talented on the
outside with wide receivers but it's
amazing in the run game and the
creativity with paid and I think it
would be an interesting matchup
like to see more Odell versus Josh
Norman sure I don't know what happened
in that rivalry it seemed like it blew
up and then it kind of faded a little
bit I am right so I'm excited for that
to happen I didn't agreed and then I
mean I would like to see Rogers against
the Jacksonville defense and then I was
just looking at like pass rusher
offensive tackles like I really did
enjoy it von Miller versus Lane Johnson
because Lane I think is the premier
right tackle in the NFL right and if
people have been reading online there is
a movement right now where a lot of
teams believe that right tackles have
become more important than left tackles
and the reason is everything ships and
waves the left tackle was so good the
pass rushers started moving over to the
right side right well now the better
tackles are moving over to the right
side yeah so that's any time that you
can get the trent williams or the Tyron
smith's
again it's like a Joey Bosa those are
just such a joy to watch yes they're
because you you almost don't want anyone
else playing you just want to see like a
battle of will yeah next question here
at call in ATK at Collin ATK oh I'm
excited to see Richard Sherman against
his old team I mean the thing I'm more
excited about is just to see Shanahan
verse McVeigh and then that was two
verse Gurdon that's they all play each
other share that to me will be the most
fun like what kind of handshake is
Gruden gonna give Kyle if Kyle like
tears them up and they end up winning by
21 points that's gonna eat at Groot in
big time I just ask the things I'm
interested to say yeah alright next
question I'm gonna skip Colin's question
for now we'll come back to it at jrg
Santos what week is usually peak
performance for NFL players already in
shape but not too banged up what week of
the season is like the Train yeah I
would I would probably even go a few
weeks after that you're close to three
but I think when you get to that week
five weeks six mid-october that's when
you feel like damn I'm in the swing of
the season my body feels great I'm
moving around good and practice my
mental states all really good that's
when I think you feel really coming week
three you start that feeling of
comfortable where you're going okay
we're in the season now here it is and
then I feel like week five
six it changes and it just it's a crazy
that's what I said that week five I'm
feeling good that is when you hit your
stride probably figuring out what the
show is gonna be what are we talking
about right I think that's fine I think
it is alright at Mikey 81 as a Packers
fan do you think the Packers are the
most underachieving team in the history
of the NFL oh man with Aaron and Brett
only winning one each hmm uh it's up
there it is up there to only have two
Super Bowls with Seahawks were pretty
underwhelming with what they had those
last few years you're right it's just
not over yet they're so the greatest
show on turf only getting one yep yeah
you're right they only got one I know
I'm trying to think it's a San Francisco
49ers and the 90s only got one yeah they
had the cow baby there were some other
problems there I'm just trying to think
of any other ones that pop up to my I
would sales what about the Patriots not
winning the Superbowl when they went
nineteen and yeah I mean I was
disappointing it's certainly unexpected
what was the the phrasing of the
question though most underachieving team
in history yeah I think it's gonna be
look people are gonna look back at it
and go man that's really disappointing I
don't think it's the most underachieving
team in history I think the most
underachieving team in the history is
probably the bills like you said that I
think of because that was a Superbowl
caliber football team right that didn't
win it but the fact that you had two of
the most physically gifted quarterbacks
in the history of the sport that are
gonna be running your franchise for
let's say when all said and done 30
years basically yeah and you only come
away with two Super Bowls it's certainly
a big disappointment I would say the
majority of Peyton Manning's time in
Indianapolis felt that way right I know
and the Chargers had LaDainian Tomlinson
and Phillip Rivers like 14 and 2 ever
yeah that really was because that they
were the best team in football you're
right that that's another team that's
that's a kind of conversation in itself
right there it's actually a fascinating
conversation because to me if we went
back through just the last few years of
Super Bowl winners I would tell you that
the team that won the Super Bowl out of
the last ten years wasn't the best team
in football that year that's what I
would say I mean again yeah I just I
think it's interesting but sorry Eagles
were the best
that's here they were they were yes that
that's that's right so weird they want
having the Patriots right I can do that
the pagers can do that I do think the
Patriots are the best team and super
like this for the year they beat the
Falcons I think they were the best team
yeah but I think the year they lost one
and beat the Seahawks I don't think they
were the best team I think the Seahawks
were the best team in that that year but
they just blew it in the end one [ __ ]
one [ __ ] play alright i watch the
f-bombs yes my podcast today all right
at Colin ADK going back to this question
which injured player from last season
who is expected to play again do you
think won't be the same so let's get rid
of Andrew Luck from that conversation
because we don't know exactly good so
you got Aaron Rodgers you have two Shaun
Watson running backs david johnson
Dalvin cook spencer where receivers
Odell Beckham Alan Robinson Quincey and
noon walk Cameron Meredith I'm just
going down the list nfl.com tight ends
Greg Olson Charles clay you say JJ Watt
hmm that's a good one to go at though I
think that JJ Watt was already declining
and I think that we also we still have
that MVP caliber season in our heads
with like the twenty and a half sacks
and all those touchdowns I think the
other one that I kind of I don't know
about is Alan Robinson I just I don't
know you know like he's just been gone
for so long and he's going to a new team
but you know if he loses a step he's a
different guy JJ Watt is certainly at
towards the top of that list I do I
don't think we'll ever see the JJ Watt
that we once saw and especially with the
type of injuries he's had lower back bad
leg injury I'm not sure he can ever
quite get back to that form I mean I you
know when you said to Sean Watson like I
don't think we're gonna see the deshaun
Watson we saw last year right away when
when I first heard that name I said yeah
I don't think we see deshaun Watson that
we saw last year to like week eight or
ten that would be one and I really think
the guy the other guy I'll throw out
there to me the guy that will not be
quite that is gonna be Eric Berry ooh
Eric Berry coming off an Achilles injury
at that position the fact that he also
had a deal with cancer and all that the
year before you know the year before
that that all those things would line up
to me to be I'd be a little worried
if maybe he lost the step going into
this season alright last question here
for inside the NFL I'm gonna pitch this
over to left go first this is a team
specific question but I couldn't resist
asking you okay you ready left go yeah
alright so this is from at I in the W
list I don't even know how you say that
when Nick Foles retires do you think the
Eagles should retire number nine Super
Bowl champ Super Bowl MVP 2014 Pro Bowl
2014 Pro Bowl offensive MVP 2013 passer
rating leader and tied the NFL record
for seven passing touchdowns in a game I
think what's most interesting is if
foals never plays again because what
happens is if he plays again it's my
potential theory like right now foals
the last thing he's ever done is throw a
touchdown to Zach Ertz yeah like that
was the end if he never plays again it's
an incredible short career for the
Eagles yes they're not retiring his
number but do you put him into the Ring
of Honor that's really really
interesting the the the first answer is
no this is where I wanted the question
to go though what's gonna happen though
is what if Carson never gets back and
then you start looking at their their
numbers and those statistics that he's
naming and you go oh yeah Carson made
you know seven Pro Bowls but what's a
Pro Bowl and oh he led the all these
statistics it's a gamete nick foles put
up 40 on the Patriots in the Super Bowl
41 I know but that's I'm not crazy I
know that Carson Wentz is the guy thank
you but I and I read a quote from Doug
Peterson recently saying that there's
literally no issue there egoless and
they're really good friends I genuinely
believe it but it's gonna be a very
funny Philadelphia sports radio debate
for a very long time yeah nasty Eagles
quarterback of all time
Noren Van Brocklin Carson Wentz er Nick
Foles it's like damn he's the only one
who won a Super Bowl yeah I know that
yeah exactly it's ridiculous just let's
let's pump the brakes on the whole Super
Bowl thing they woulda won of course and
once was there too and we wouldn't have
questions in the week Sweden leading up
to that either about that I mean people
forget everybody wanted Nick Bowles to
be benched at the end of the year for an
eighth son fell including myself exactly
so I just yes Nick fall
has had some special moments with the
Philadelphia Eagles I don't think in any
way fashion and touchdowns in the game
against the I mean that was an
impressive little list you read right
there but it all said and done I don't
need seven touchdowns enough I don't
think it's long enough all right we're
moving on to the legs and ass section
here we might come back to some more NFL
questions later legs only one legs and
asked question and it's not even about
legs and ass a roux 8:11 a roux 8:11
first off I love you guys been a
listener for three years and they lost a
whole new love for the game more of a
technical question for me why are some
quarterbacks arms less muscular than
others I'm thinking of the goat Aaron
Rodgers arms versus a dak Prescott dak
seems jacked is that a good thing you're
like Sam Bradford yeah I joke about his
arms all the time right but you tell me
throws a great ball a super great spot
that trail mix left calm that's good
sounds good in my ears Newton jacked
right so okay this is listen you're you
can have muscles you just don't want to
have muscles to the fact where you feel
like it's constricting your actual
motion exactly right that's when you get
too thick and too big like that it's why
you don't see really pitchers in
baseball built like that either they're
not trying to like be bench press and
curl champions of the world because the
flexibility of your arm right that's
your catapult it needs to be able to be
flexible and get into some of those
weird positions Aaron Rodgers is a
little more muscular and rip than people
would realize but yes there's a fine
line with NFL quarterbacks in just being
able to oh I want to be in state in
shape have a little strength have a
little armor to be able to protect
myself but don't want to overdo it to
where I lose six degrees of my motion
because I can benchpress an extra 40
pounds how do you explain that a Sam
Bradford with seemingly no muscular
definition in his arms throwing such
great balls well yes I mean how do you
explain Michael Jordan with no ass and
no hamstring who can have a 48 inch
vertical I don't know I know because
it's levers and the size of the man and
things like that look Sam Bradford's big
taller than me right really yeah yeah
you'd see Sam Bradford to go old man
he's not the skinny noodle I thought he
was I know he doesn't have a lot of
money
he's got big hands and he of course has
a little more muscular power than you're
giving him credit for and the long
sleeve jerseys gonna yeah I know he's
got a natural motion in general are
there any quarterbacks that you're like
oh he's too built yeah I came at times
but I haven't seen it affect his
throwing so I I mean cam is a guy I look
at and go wow yeah that's pretty jacked
right there and then we did have that
question about Russell Wilson like you
said we with the training camp two years
ago we were like damn rubbing against
each other well that's what's so
interesting I think about Lamar and I go
talk about like a long sinewy arm you
know I mean works like these like long
muscles most guys are built like that
quarterbacks they're more than wiry type
muscle guys that can't necessarily
really even get thick if they wanted
like me like I couldn't get real thick
like you couldn't I don't think so not
beats
did you ever try I mean my junior year
in college I think was the heaviest I
ever played at I was like 238 maybe
right around there close to 240 and I
don't heavy I did I do not like the way
I felt but my you know my strength coach
at the time that was daunte culpepper
he's raised to 60 so all quarterbacks
were gonna be yes but no it makes no
sense to try to be big and like I always
told you guys most guys get to the NFL
and they go damn I'm too big I need to
lose 20 pounds yeah cuz everyone the
NFL's just speeds yes it's about the
speed and body maintenance and extra
weight hurts the body maintenance all
right we're moving on to the
free-for-all section that was our only
legs and asked question next time around
everyone send us more questions about
legs and ass all right so this section
is pretty much just all the random
questions that I pulled together some
for left go some for Sims some for both
of you so left go we're gonna start with
you here Collin Crilley at undercover
eagle you have the chance to interview
any athlete in the world for bleacher
report who are you pickin Wow any
athlete in the world in the whole world
I know I'm picking there you go first
I'm picking man actually I don't know
who I'm picking between LeBron James and
Aaron Rodgers okay
it's one of us to Dan Odell Beckham jr.
it's a true a trio I think if you made
me do one and oh dollar definitely I
think Aaron is the guy I would go with I
mean I've been told he's going to come
on in this podcast they're a little
I know watch your mouth I just feel like
you're the drug dealer it's like I got
it it's coming don't worry now Rogers
yeah I got I get the Rogers I'm saying
it again my first thought was Richard
Sherman that was like kind of the first
one I know that we've talked to him
before I just like talking if like I'd
really like to interview Steve Smith I
like guys that just Yap and are really
confident
Odell Aaron Rodgers obviously but anyone
in the entire world I would pick the guy
that's playing for the LA Galaxy it's
not on his lot on his lot on is this
incredible guy that like disrespects
like anyone that's not him and is always
looking to drop an incredible quote and
I just I think he's fantastic
he's the guy that was on menu who is
this guy he lost me at LA Galaxy he was
he's like a Sweden national team player
he was on PSG as PSG great goal in his
first game in LA over a biscuit next
question here Jack wolf at RWS Wolf Man
182 this is a story got a little
traction on Twitter the other day not
sure what caused that I think you said
something on pft can you please have
Chris tell the story of how he got fine
for throwing the food Wednesday's you
guys did it on Wednesday yeah did I not
hear that all right well just anyways
getting fine in the NFL it's it's it's
goes on you can't play in the NFL
without getting fine yeah so you throw a
ball on the stands you can find $2,500 I
think if you do it the second time it
doubles right same thing with socks if
anybody else wants to know that I used
to get fine for socks right yeah you get
fine for socks like if you're on the
Tampa Bay Bucs and they have black and
white on their sock you have to have a
certain amount of white and black
showing and they have people there to
check that [ __ ] so it used to drive me
crazy cuz I want to wear my socks the
way I want to wear them how would you
work how they feel good and
importantly how they look good cuz I
want to look good because then I'll play
good so I'd like to have a lot of black
but I started to realize if I went out
in pregame warm-ups with all the black I
get warned and then if I don't do it I
get fine so I started to finagle a line
it doubles every twenty five hundred
first time next time you get say five
thousand seventy five hundred then the
fat then ten thousand and twelve five
keeps going at home find the same amount
of Sox is usually throwing a ball in the
stands yes but more actually as you
continue to do it like guys like Charles
Woodson gave a hundred and forty
thousand in the NFL because they warden
to wear their socks just wear socks the
way they want a 145 here you go whatever
it was when it's all said and done it's
somewhere around along those lines but
yeah so what it would piss me off
what does he do with that money and you
have certain guys who who check on the
sidelines right and you know sometimes
we're like oh this guy's a pretty cool
uniform checker like he's not gonna be
like like be crazier but then you had
other guys where I'd run out once out
the tape measure
well I'd run out in the field of like
you know just like the pregame pregame
was shorts and a t-shirt and I beg oh
it's that guy today [ __ ] a that guy
he's good he's like mister uniform like
you know Soup Nazi over here he's just
all over you to where I I would then I
realize you know what so I'm gonna go
out for pregame warmups
and I'm gonna wear some correct socks
because they have to warn you before
they can find you but the problem is
even when you do that they come in at
halftime I was going to say they're not
coming up to you like after the first
drive and go and I know you threw a pick
but like you got a fix yourself okay
they might say something like that some
of them sometimes do we shut the [ __ ] up
in like good I got other things to worry
about
you took her in your jersey if [ __ ] off
but then they would come into the locker
room so you're gumming in Locker it's a
tight game and they're like let go not
enough white vendrick not enough black
tuck in your jersey 34 your jockstraps
showing seven o'clock just talking over
him no it's like they get you as soon as
you've gotten in there and they
literally walk by you to make sure
you've heard you that's your warning and
that's my warning and I think I'm right
not if you get fined and I into the game
oh no Tuesday you'll have the FedEx on
your lockers that you're gonna walk in
damn there it is that's another question
alright so when you would be in the
locker room your paychecks are sitting
in an envelope in an envelope right
FedEx er no just an envelope white
envelope but if you're seeing FedEx if
you're seeing FedEx you know it's from
the NFL so what Charles Woodson just
write the check at the beginning of the
season oh they dot they'll take it out
of your pay because the condom is also
gonna get the same letter you got to say
that you violated rules within the CBA
so they're gonna know now to withhold
twenty five hundred from whatever amount
they're supposed to give you on your
next check dams so you're sitting there
you're the only person in the world that
doesn't like to see a package oh you
don't want to see it package now now
you're in trouble do you got a package
you got a FedEx your your impact you're
in trouble driving tests well you know
Derrick Coleman story the Derrick
Coleman story like first day he comes
like the nets or the Sixers river it was
he's like late to the team bus and
they're just like alright well listen I
mean that'sthat's a thousand dollar fine
it was it was suits and ties on the road
suits and ties on the road yeah and they
go we're gonna $1,000 if you don't wear
a suit and tie in the road and he
thought about it and he said damn okay
alright that's it's 39 games because
they didn't count the ones for the New
York yes so way games and he went to the
coach the next day the story is and said
here's a check for forty thousand this
should cover me yeah Mark Zuckerberg for
wearing the same shirt every day Derrick
Coleman spending forty thousand dollars
not to worry about suits yeah in
anything he probably would have spent
that much money on suits yeah you're
right no you're right yeah all right
next question here at you Ventus one
thousand left go we're coming to you
first on this one who would you start
your franchise with Randy Moss or Deion
Sanders
alright so we're assuming prime and you
get them for the entire career correct
mmm that's a good question
starting your franchise Randy Moss or
Deion Sanders you ventus 1000 we're
coming a left go first here take your
time
I know it's good question I am going to
say I'm going with Randy I was gonna go
with Deion Oh Randy I'm gonna go with
Randy I'm just I don't know I'm a
quarterback but yeah I'm gonna go with
Randy I
I think that Dion it's weird because you
can go Dion's the only one that could
cover someone like Randy and then
Randy's the only one that could get past
a guy like dia
yeah Dion was somebody that liked okay
so they both had some distractions off
the field Dion played a number of sports
was always asking for high salaries was
willing to test the free agent market
I'm assuming though I get him for the
whole time yeah Randy did have off the
field issue he did run into a cop he did
have some other stuff you know he had
about a three four year span in Oakland
where people were not high on him yes so
I don't think Dion ever had a low and
his career like Randy did and this is
all due respect like his career was
amazing he's top to wide receiver of all
time and that's why I give it to Dion I
get that his Dion's the number one
corner of all time yeah and I don't
think it's a debate and I think with
Randy there's a slight debate with him
and Jerry Rice right I'm not gonna end
Terrell Owens but I'm gonna put Randy in
jail I'm gonna put Randy over to you
yeah I do too there I mean maybe Randy
is number one
Jerry's tough cuz I don't know where to
do it it is it is tough but Randy is
always putting pressure on a defense
like you you have to have two guys or
one guy deep Dion cuts off half the
field yes but I think with Dion you both
get did Randy Moss ever return kicks her
punts he did a little bit early on but
it wasn't much but Dion was and Dion
also had time at wide receiver Dion
played a few years as a wide receiver
option so he was kind of doing both
Randy Moss also played defensive back on
Hail Marys you can't go wrong now you
can't go wrong i under your points are
valid totally I go with Randy just
because cooler it's it's Dion's cooler
but Randy is cool still and I would go
with Randy just because it's offense
it sells tickets I feel like I could do
more with him on a consistent weekly
basis where Dion if you played a smart
team they would go let's just keep him
out there void him all game that would
be my only reason I may be my final
because Sims is thinking about selling
tickets anyone he always he always wants
a sell ticket next question fear the
beard 972 a question for Chris Sims
worst hazing at any level that Sims has
seen in his football career oh yeah man
gosh one of the worst ones I ever got
just right off the bat was a kid when I
was on the as a freshman I played
varsity football high school high school
and oh man I'm gonna forget his name
Frasier oh man I don't say his name
well either way he gave me a purple
nurple and he ripped my nurple off okay
I mean I lost like the the center of it
for like a year you lost the tip of a
bull for a year and he quit pinched it
and twisted it so hard and show that he
had skin no no he did not him where did
it go I don't have fell on the ground
but all I knew was I looked down and I
was bleeding on my nipple and it was
like a year yes this was a senior that
did this is a senior yes sensitive
nipples now I don't but man he stole the
sensitivity from you no no you know what
I do have sense that's why I wear a wife
beater really more times than not I
always have I wear my wife beater
because when the shirt rubs against my
nipples it annoys my nipples they get a
little raw on the top all because that
one vulnerable I mean I think you know
my worst hazing one ever Dewey
the Alstott one all style ones good I
mean I always go back to any time and
often so I mean the offensive lying
buying a whole bottle of louis xiii that
costs $15,000 that's pretty bad to make
a rookie you have to pay for that I like
the all-star one you like the all stop
one with the guy named Jeb Terry
remember we've got a lot of new
listeners who may not get right right
you're right I'm sorry so I'll share my
hazing story after yeah oh you got some
high school basketball stories yes davon
Joseph it was a first-round pick
offensive line dinner they used to
brookie hayes we all go out to dinner
it's like a $17,000 tab but then our
offensive lineman Center John Wade
decided to you know lay it on a little
bit so he bought a bottle of louis xiii
that cost fifteen thousand dollars that
would be that one and then the all stop
ones great job with harry home before
you talk what would happen if the rookie
was like very miserable what happens to
be Irish exited maybe his life would be
miserable in what way and the things
that what I'm about to say Mike Alstott
did to Jeb Terry cuz Jeb Terry didn't
get him a Gatorade one day
so let's do that so let's do this can
you hey Brooke can you get me a Gatorade
and he looked at Mike and he looked at
Mike Alstott
and then he goes no man Brooke give me
your Gatorade and he blocked away and
just left and he's like aw you're gonna
pay for that and all thought was the man
you don't want to miss a loss not when
Frank's came down and all okay okay
you're gonna pay for that and all snot
sat in the corner of whatever so then a
few days go by I see all stop doing this
and I know he's gonna get him back but
I'm in the facility one day and like
Jeb's got his car there for some reason
but he's not there and all SOT calls
gets these few of the equipment guys and
gets a few people that know cars and
they put this kid's truck on a top of
cinder blocks take the wheels off hang
them from the field goal post on the
practice field and then he took the hood
of the car off to where when JEB walked
in the locker room the next morning the
hood was at his locker and that was an
all-timer I mean that was a great one it
wasn't females were over the gold papers
hanging from strings so what do you guys
want to practice where they were just
off they were out there right I'm like
hi there how did Gruden react to that oh
good love that crap did they stop
practice like get him down
no no they were left there doesn't get a
random goalpost and only the few little
kickers kicked on at times and then it
became gem having to call like AAMCO
after everything that guy needs somebody
here to put four wheels on a Boise
Pistor did he get it uh he was pissed
and he got it
but yeah I mean it was stupid we were
all like Jeb he's Mike Alstott why
didn't you just get him a Gatorade like
what were you trying to prove there that
yeah like we're too cool to do that and
what he said I'm not gonna let that guy
step all over me all over too many too
many movies about jail you got to pick a
fight with the toughest guy but
apparently not no and apparently not
that's what my dad's brothers used to
say to me when I was that freshman on
that varsity didn't they go you know you
should do should go pick a fight with
the toughest guy on the team and I was
like damn I will get my ass kicked if I
got a catfight that guy we got one
nipple dad it's the same guy that ripped
my nipple up I'm already scared of them
man can't believe ya
I don't have big nipples anyway I
actually didn't have to do a deep dive
episode on that alright Luke parents I
have a mole right by the other nipple so
it almost looks like I got three nipples
guys how's that for a headline alright
Luke Parrish a tell Parrish 22 left goes
is gonna be our last Eagles question of
the podcast yeah left go who is one
player from past Eagles teams the hunted
ones yeah that's what was the question
from past Eagle seems that you would
want to join the current team oh yeah
[ __ ] Brian Dawkins I will say this I I
said this during you know a Reggie White
or anything that uh I think that people
don't appreciate Brian Westbrook's
career enough yeah and I don't I think
he came about ten years too early right
in the NFL I feel like if Brian
Westbrook came out now he would be seen
as the perfect running back an
incredible past catcher he was averaging
like over five yards of carry and I I
know that Andy Reed knew how to use him
but I don't think we appreciated him
enough back then Reggie White is a
timeless person that could no I know
what you mean you're gonna anything
you're going Dawkins at the end of the
day Dawkins
I just it was he was a guy that before
the game got the energy up because his
entrance was unlike anything you've ever
seen during the game he would make plays
that were always showstoppers and then
the end of the game there was no guy
that gave a better postgame speech like
he was the team man you should have
heard him in the locker room before the
games he was even more amazing now gun
it oh my gosh he was unreal like I've
said I've never seen a transformation of
a player more than when I saw Brian
Dawkins he was mr. holy quiet humble guy
Monday through Saturday we came in for
the first game when I was in Denver with
Brian Dawkins pregame and I was like who
is this person that is a madman in our
locker room right now and it was Brian
Dawkins and I didn't believe it at first
I was like man this isn't real is this
real like is he like faking it right now
but it was amazing it went on all year
long it was the biggest transformation I
ever saw of a player in my eight-year
career where I went he's one guy six
days a week and on this set
today man you don't want to fight him on
the seventh day yeah he so in his
everyone's putting together their Hall
of Fame lockers all the guys that got in
and he's putting in his Clemson Jersey
the Eagles Wolverine and and the
wolverine figurines and a thing that
says Weapon X yeah he's obsessed with
the x-men character Wolverine and he
believes like that's why he goes like
this yes it's like the Wolverine claws
to lockers in Denver yeah he had two
lockers of the Philadelphia lockers I've
never heard of it out like getting two
lockers just for all of his Wolverine
ones holy yes totally Wolverine
memorabilia yes all right next question
it is the incredible mulk 14 hey left's
key and Scott beavis and butt-head what
was Sims favorite place games great what
was Sims favorite play to run under Jon
Gruden Gruden is obviously known for
spider 2 y banana so I was wondering if
Sims had a favorite play of his oh if
you have any you have to do the actual
play yeah the full play call yeah
alright yeah it's Dan there's so many
good ones here I mean I'd loved anything
that meant Joey Galloway was going deep
right I mean so we did have a play of
where it was like it was like soul left
snug 59 ex special so you just it was
actually an easy play call they had a no
ex special meant it was special and Joey
was gonna run this special post route 59
ex-special and then we would can it with
like 300 jets sticky right which would
be just little stick routes like hey
inside guys run a five-yard out then the
guys that are just outside of you run
little routes into the flat route into
the flat that would be that was one of
my favorite cause because just from this
simple reason Joey Galloway of course
was one of the fastest humans to ever
play in football you get him in a tight
split that's why it was a solo snug
right solo snug brought him in tight
where I knew he wasn't gonna get try and
kind of come up in the combo get up to
the safety and go lean him out like oh
I'm gonna run a flag route out and then
that safety would wide and then he'd
turn it up and go inside him and if he
was even he was leaving so if I said oh
he's getting close let me just launch
this [ __ ] out there cuz he's gonna go
run it down would you rather throw a
deep post or a deep go Oh probably a
deep post
I feel like post is the
most enjoyable deep throat of three it
is pretty it is pretty gratifying I also
like 72 all go special alert it with a
clap love the clap okay the claps a
dangerous disease on your table so 72
all go special alert clap right what is
that so alert clap would know give me
this 72 all go special 72 all go special
would be your three by one just all go
right all go everybody go but it's three
receivers to one side and only one on
the backside and that inside ones
basically almost running like a deep
cross yes and then use this on them yeah
I'm sure it's it's a it's a Steve Madden
staple but what was great is when we got
covered - I could clap it right I could
clap it so I'd go booty five bullet if I
said hahaha and that was a dummy snap
count I think oh they're gonna play
cover two and I'd get up and now we knew
oh they're playing Tampa - so that
middle linebacker is gonna fly down all
go specials not a good play for this so
let's someone stay and then we're gonna
make everybody know we're gonna send all
those guys going vertical they're all
gonna go like ten yards and curl now
Tampa - the middle linebackers way down
the middle of the field now there's only
two linebackers left well if I made the
back I like five yards to the left
the tight end right over the ball where
the mic was and then that third receiver
another like 10-yard curl through you're
playing three on two right and that's
what you would do those were one of them
are some of my favorites snug ex-special
solo left snug 59 X special candidate
three hundred Jets sticky yeah a fan of
candidate and clapping it I always
cannon clapping all right Josh Hugh
Valley can you guys talk about what
makes a good wide receiver so many of
these guys have similar measurables and
see some success while others don't why
is that I want to say this before we get
into this conversation
I saw a Brandon Marshall Instagram where
he posted a picture of him and Doug
Baldwin yeah and he said this is one of
the best wide receivers of all time and
I didn't realize it until I got up close
and he listed IQ hands stuff like that
yeah I will admit if I'm doing self
scouting that we are always more partial
to the more physical specimen right it's
just the way we are sure as I think most
people should be if you're bigger and
faster you're bigger and faster so we
are very partial to the Odell's and the
Julio's and the AJ greens but I do think
we miss out a little bit on the Antonio
Browns the Doug ball
wins and the guys that are just masters
yeah underneath or out running the craft
but matters of what makes a great wide
receiver his hands the first thing or is
it not the first thing I it's it's I
take it for granted at almost right yeah
I mean hands are the first thing they're
the first thing yes I mean hands and
speed of the first thing I go to what's
a more important speed or quickness if
you're more slot oriented it's going to
be quickness but I'm still gonna go with
speed at the end of the day because
that's the fear yeah yes that's the fear
to me speed is again the number one
thing because the guys you just
mentioned right or well look at the guys
you just mentioned you know Odell Julio
AJ Green those are guys that can do more
with less oh you threw me a five yard
pass well Doug Baldwin's awesome but I
don't remember highlights of him making
four people miss you all right second
Doug Baldwin will never get a five yard
pass but they're gonna catch it they are
gonna catch yes you're right
and they're gonna be ultra dependable
dictates how the house know so to me
it's it's kind of about speed your hips
your feet your hands your feel of the
game right that's where the great ones
can really separate themselves the feel
of the game then little nuances and
route running and things like that's
where like Antonio Browns awesome he
understands the defensive rules or how
this d-back the defensive back plays me
in certain coverages and I'm gonna take
advantage of those things that I saw in
film all week and use that to my
advantage and route running you also
begin to realize that but speed is still
number one
I mean it's number one Randy Moss is the
second greatest receiver of all time yes
because he's tall and all those things
but he's arguably in his prime was one
of the fastest receivers of all time
same with Terrell Owens same with Oda
Buckham jr. I also think we laugh about
it during the draft and stuff in terms
of ball skills but some guys are really
good at playing the ball in the air yes
and and it's like Antonio Brown men his
ability to catch it off his helmet
running the side-to-side using different
hands like he is just a DeAndre Hopkins
is
beat our incredible hands are better
than anybody
when DeAndre Hopkins is near the
sideline I've never seen someone toe
drag yeah
DeAndre Hopkins feet are so good that
the field is almost five yards wider on
either side because his radius he can go
all the way out right and and so he's
creating parts to throw two that don't
even exist for other people yes I mean
yes his in his ability to catch in
traffic I think is the best in football
but again I push back with guys like
DeAndre Hopkins is the same way other
than the Seattle game last year where
the Red Sea parted show me plays where
he went 60 and 70 yards after the catch
four touchdowns that's still what
differentiates the special guys I love
the same conversation with quarterbacks
when people try to say that arm strength
doesn't matter listen I know it's not
the end-all be-all but it's really
important and that's where I think
people miss out on it yeah the greatest
receivers of all time are some of the
fastest receivers of all time and that's
what made them great it's their
potential of impact it is and it's also
the what they do fearful wise to the
defense and the guy that's covering them
that allows them to open up other things
that are in both that's why I love Odell
Beckham jr. the Odell Beckham jr.
everything we just said about all the
other guys and the freak shows back
shoulder catching of jump balls man all
these highlights I see on TV or Eli
throwing ducks and him jumping up and
catching the ball so he can do that I'll
let alone knowing the nuances of the
route running and the after the catch
stuff dude Odell is a amazing route
runner people lose that in translation
pleat complete you do realizing we don't
give enough credit to otro sync oh yeah
oh just think it was an amazing run had
the speed and his route running was
incredible to charts yeah it was ma'am
all right one more question here the
receivers are the best then we're gonna
go to the lightning round to wrap it up
here
Jake Bentley at Jake Bentley if you were
a high school five-star recruit what
school would you go - so let's eliminate
Texas for you because you you did go to
Texas size you go anywhere you can go
anywhere so the first thought is Alabama
but you're gonna realize that you might
not be able to play right away
you are in the middle of Alabama in the
middle of Alabama there's other sides
though you will be drafted possibly
earlier than maybe you should have
you're gonna get a professional pedigree
USC I think is an amazing college
experience and they also have the NFL
cachet exactly
I don't think Miami is there Florida is
is pretty good but I feel like it's not
gonna have as good of facilities what
also I miss like who are the really big
ones like there's Michigan there's Ohio
State is the one that jumped to my mind
first lose are just Pro factors there's
Pro factories they have an atmosphere
you like as far as a college it's it's
footballs life
Urban Meyer like aid Nike Nick Saban is
very detailed but not crazily detailed
where I feel like his guys have a little
more freedom like Ohio State with Urban
Meyer's the first place I thought up I
mean if you're a top-five recruit you're
looking at like this I want to go
somewhere where footballs big and where
can I get to the NFL and to me right now
for schools jump out above the rest and
that's Alabama Georgia Clemson and Ohio
State no four I think are in a class of
their own right now with their coaches
the programs the skill level players
they have right there like I don't think
they're going anywhere anytime soon here
in the recent future if you're a
quarterback let's say you're you yeah
number one quarterback in the country
number one player and Nick Saban comes
to you yeah do you want to play for a
school that hasn't put an NFL
quarterback in the end like I know AJ
McCarron but like have do you want to
play for the school that hasn't had it I
find that intrigue right because it's
like it hasn't been done right that's
why I like Texas a little bit cuz I like
damn their name there's they don't even
know what a quarterback looks like down
there that's an NFL chords you go out of
those four though Ohio State and play
for Urban Meyer Nick Saban Clemson and
all those athletes and I had a receiver
that I don't have I know and then
Georgia which I mean that kids their
third I think Notre Dame probably
deserves to be in this conversation with
sc2 I know I am a home of a Notre Dame
thing that's in your national TV and you
become a well-rounded man it's it's a
little different than most colleges I'm
doing it just because it's like it run
like a professional team and you know
just the actual focus on stuff
are a little greater there than Alabama
and Georgia and Clemson I'm sorry that's
just the truth of the matter but who I'm
just trying to study no you're right I'm
not I know but his life I think the
place I would go to I would I would go
to Ohio State I don't know why I just
like Urban Meyer I like Ohio State but
man
out of those four schools I'd be pretty
happy with any four of them man I'm
picking Arizona nice I think it depends
what position like if I'm an offensive
lineman I kind of want to be in the big
ten just because people trust a big 10
line Minnesota Wisconsin yep if you're
in the if you're a wide receiver in the
big 12 you're gonna have a great time if
you're gonna put out like 7,000 yards
but for me I'm going to Arizona because
it's a beautiful place with um in
college and you go three and eight every
year it sauce
we're gonna go for five more minutes
here we're gonna call this a lightning
dancer with Syracuse yeah I was gonna
say no Rutgers talk during that segment
interesting all right we'll have to talk
about that well I think the pump in fake
crowd noise do we want to go there left
go come on let's save it for another
podcast okay lightning round here last
five minutes I'm gonna just go back and
forth here read the question you give me
your answer and then we'll move on to
the next one left go we're gonna start
with you here knockout news at knockout
news Rams are Eagles who is the better
all-around team going into this season
and why Eagles the issue that I see I
see all the potential the offense on the
Rams and all that my issue with the Rams
is the middle of their defense no one's
talking about and I think there's a hole
and I look at the Eagles team and I
don't see a similar hole do you agree
with that I do I do it's very close the
Rams are scary but I also think that the
Eagles have more continuity on their
football team in general than the Rams
do who have just brought four superstars
to town and that's a little bit of a
juggling match so it they're got a lot
of potential in the Los Angeles but I
still would go to the Eagles to Joshua
Bell 11 Kris start with you on this also
what if it doesn't go great and Marcus
Peters gonna keep deliver on the same
day that's what I mean they might be
talking to Jonathan soon right is it
better for Calvin Ridley that Julio
Jones is not at Camp with Julio gone
would really be seeing more reps with
Matt Ryan and get better adjusted to NFL
speed great point and
yes and yes to both yes fix Calvin
Ridley's getting some attention that he
wouldn't get if Julio Jones is there now
you're a first round pick they're always
all over you because they're your new
shining toy and they got to prove that
you're gonna be good to justify you know
their draft pick there but not having
Julio there that will allow them to
feature him more in some OTAs and things
and maybe just pressure push a little
more on them than they normally would
have so I do think it's a good thing
it's still gonna be better than when he
sees Julio there in person he realized
wow this is Julio this is what the best
receiver in football looks like I need
to raise my game and just there was
always talk last year with the Eagles
when how Shawn Jeffery got their that
all of a sudden all the other wide
receivers had a benchmark to look at
yeah and and you know Julio is one of
those guys he's gonna be there before
everybody and after huh so you could get
more reps but maybe they're more useful
reps watching holy I think so Simon
Morley at swim coach si what do the
Bears need to do to take them over the
top they have a pretty decent pretty
decent defense they added a lot of
offensive weapons to go with a really
solid offensive line I think that they
just need to execute to their potential
like I think the big issue with the
Bears in my opinion other than not
having a wide receiver talent is that
their offensive line keeps getting
banged up and I don't think that can
happen every year and I think if true
Biscay has time with all of the weapons
they have on offense it's gonna be
interesting i I think that one that team
is a little bit overhyped right now
against a lot of new additions right and
they need to be able to stop people and
pass defense right but I think that they
had the potential to go seven and nine
eight and eight and and and have
everyone really excited for next year
yes I think there's a lot of great in
Chicago keeping Fangio amazing Negi
awesome Allen Robinson some of the other
guys they brought there and free agency
traybird and all those I think the this
would be the biggest thing for me a
young young football team like they got
getting when getting a winner too early
on the year that will truly change the
year beware if they start off oh and for
then they're gonna go for in 12 but if
they start off like two and two that's
where they can get to what Lefko said
that's seven and nine eight and eight
who knows nine and seven if they pull
off magic in a game or two whatever it
may be
I think that's big for a young football
team Packers Seahawks Cardinals
Buccaneers those are their first four
games they can win some of those they
get a three and one they could they can
go to and - for sure - yes so you're
right they there's potential there to
get things going in the right way
Sam's gonna start with you on this one
this question from Daquan Booker @dl
book how good could DeForest Buckner be
he gets overlooked so much when they
talk about the inside deal on guys and
he is a monster monster DeForest Buckner
can be like a coleus Campbell
I think ultimate end game potential
because of the size the way he's built
he's such a huge man he can be
overpowering for a tall guy - he's
really good at staying on his feet when
getting chop blocked and things like
that so he has the type of potential to
be an all-pro type player him Arik
Armstead Salomon Thomas yeah did they
hit on any of them did they miss on any
I think Buckner is the best one what
about Armstead Armstead still has
potential - like Armstead showed some
improvement last year the weirdest thing
for them right now
is they went from running the bear
scheme where they fit to now running
Jacksonville scheme where it's an
adjustment for that type of guy now they
have to attack exactly exactly right and
Salomon Thomas is a really good player I
don't know if he can ever be a superstar
which is why you take him at 3 I know
but it was a weird draft that kind of
got stuck and I think that he can be a
really good player for a long time I
don't know if he can ever be a superstar
you get with what oh you were about to
lean I thought this is your when you
lean in I think you're amazing I'm so
used to seeing you like address the
microphone alright let go let's see
Jonathan with at Jonathan with do the
Jets have a top 5 secondary in 2018 so
it's the two safeties yeah I'm gonna
pull up the wrong guy
Tremaine Johnson right you're right
Tremaine Johnson resigned Morris
Claiborne right I'm pulling them up for
you just so you can hear a bit so it's
definitely arguable top five it is up
there
I think Safety's alone they arguably
have the best safety common they know
along with Buster screen we're
forgetting right I think they're our top
five secondary they're in that
conversation the safeties are phenomenal
the safety is definitely are tied
I don't think there's another safety duo
and then when you look at just Tremaine
Johnson Buster's screen and Morris
Claiborne I go that's a top 10 top 12
yeah so when you factor that with top 5
Safety's I think they're probably a top
5
I think so too the thing that's
interesting too is they have little
other guys that play on their team too
that I think are good players I kind of
get lost under the radar a little bit
like the Darryl Roberts kid and who's
the other one I was thinking of Justin
Burris you know there's depth to it too
along with like the top end talent you
talked about so I I do think that they
are in that top three when there was a
moment where it looked like the Jets
were gonna get Marcus may Jamal Adams
Tremaine Johnson and Malcom Butler that
was gonna be insane it would have been
that so you asked about the Bears
earlier yep my super team that I only
know was talking about the Titans I
think when you combine their playoff
experience with Vrabel now on defense
and the additions they put their Dean
P's and Matt Lafleur on offense and I
think that Derek Henry fits that that
kind of zone running scheme really well
kind of rounding it off and going up
yeah and then with you know like and
Delanie Walker in that scheme too
I have a feeling that the Titans might
go 12 and for 13 and 3 and everyone's
talking about the Shawn Watts and
everyone's talked about the Jaguars and
the Titans might come out of nowhere and
win that division that's the team that's
in my head right yeah alright last
question here before we wrap this up
Sims we'll go to you on this one at
Eastland beats could Derek Carr being
the MVP talks with martavis and Jordi
and Gruden and Olsen running the offense
yes sir he can be you know a little bit
later great candidate for it to get
Awards because they're gonna clearly
exceed what they did last year they're
gonna you want one thing you're gonna
you're right they're gonna exceed
because the system is better the players
around them are better and it's the
first year where the head coach is gonna
go man I'm supposed to be an offensive
coach and I got to make sure my offense
gets off to a good start
you know we forget a little like Carson
Wentz last year Derek Carr was I think
going to win the MVP two years ago yes
right when he breaks his leg against the
Indianapolis Colts
they were like nine and three all those
comeback wins he had that were
phenomenal that year he made a number
fising according Faraj yeah I was gonna
say this is five or six I got
fourth-quarter comeback to one that
maybe that year was that thing that was
I was Matt Ryan that's why it was that I
thought Matt Ryan here so that would
have been interesting but it moving very
close
he has MVP caliber talent there's no
doubt last year with the back injury I
think it affected him but the system
with those three receivers and then what
really I think is gonna be the other
step-up that's going to improve that
offense which Gruden will bring is the
the tight end back out of the backfield
combination will be another number of
easy completions and yards for a car
because Gruden so good at last year it
was like like car sitting back there
like waiting for [ __ ] to develop exactly
you know how many like weird questions
for us like weird I mean we got some
weird questions but I do want two more
two more I'm excited you want a couple
weird ones
yeah just like personal like you know
who's the big spoon type of style right
let's see a left go let me go to the
weird section here okay did you have a
weird section no I had a couple weird
questions but I went I went more with
someone more the football question do
boy this alright hold on one second
okay stop where was my weird okay
absence coaches took the show back it
was like this was my at Sim underscore
in who can drink more beer in one
sitting I've got my money on Sims well
Sims doesn't drink beer I mean I don't I
can pound him down there pretty good I
know that fender ik thinks that he's
probably the one that could drink the
most you know what I saw this question
come in I did it did cross my mind I
would I might actually go with Fender ik
you think so because Fender ik is a
weird strategy guy like he's got a
certain way to eat wings I only use my
right hand I feel like he would have
like a breathing technique for drinking
the most beer I think that if we did a
competition I would probably come in
last Joshua come in first and you would
come in second I feel like you would
just want to beat me and then you would
be we would overlook Josh the entire
time I mean I'm an endurance drinker I
can sit there for six hours and just do
patient like I don't know yeah I'm - I'm
like whatever you want to drink in that
six hours let's just get out of the way
in the first six minutes
luckily yes I drink tequila yeah I mean
the beer the thing that gets me the beer
is I just feel like it's it's in my
stomach right I get so full you know
what's helped me out a lot I saw a video
online that when you're pouring a beer
you're not supposed to like get it in
there so there's like no like foam on
top you're supposed to like port so all
the foam comes out because otherwise you
drink it and it gets in your stomach
like it expands in your stomach it's
helped me drink a lot of beer alright
this one from our sims in left go senior
music producer and music consultant rod
Simba Helen you gotta get rod in there
water seems that left goes middle names
ooh Chris what's your middle initial
what just give me your middle initial D
I am em and Josh what's your middle
initial d oh I'm gonna say what do you
think Chris is my name is he's a D I
think I know I think it's David I was D
it was an M is David Chris David's name
is David Stonewall okay as you were
raised on story court and my middle name
is David Stonewall okay so then what do
you think josh is my name is Dee Dee I
think he's Daniel I think he's a David -
Daniel Nathan Daniel what street did you
grow up on I actually have a good one
Daniel tuxedo tuxedo in the return of
big boobs starts with an M and Michael
nope Matthew yes Wow
and my going to read it I am Matthew
Springwood now classic I grew up on
spring would play that is awesome
Matthew spring would that's what I'm
gonna start calling you around the your
Davis don't a David Stonewall
so David Stone Wow yes Daniel tuxedo and
Matthew spring whoo and my wife is like
you she's a good one - she's Maria
Saddleback
[Music]
the Bears at Cog 7 your magically - more
- more
this is the last one this is the last
like juicy one that I have your
magically trapped in an elevator a
spacious one all you have is a cooler
full of beer one CD and a boombox
maintenance is coming in 4 hours to fix
it you're trapped with three current NFL
players which three players are you
wishing to get stuck with and what CD oh
man man for hours please pull up the
teams for hours all right so the music
things the first thing I got to think of
here I mean I think was something like
that you got to go with an all-time
great like if I'm going rap or anything
like that I'm going you know jay-z I'm
going Drake Kendrick Lamar dad I don't
even know if like Kendrick Lamar and
Drake will have four hours worth of
music yet so jay-z Led Zeppelin those
are things I think of peyer's now Aaron
Rodgers done Odell Beckham jr. are damn
gonna be on that elevator with me so
just so let's get that off to write up
give us at least one wife hmm I'm gonna
probably get Jadeveon Clowney cuz he
could probably do something freakishly
awesome to get the elevator to go up to
the next floor maybe just open the damn
doors bigger so I'm going to Devi on cuz
I love him and I have a man crushing
them and then mmm and I'm going with
people I like but this guy can have
fights in the elevator and then that
would be up okay that's good yeah I'll
take that I am going to go Nick Falls
Carson wind music music wise Lauryn Hill
like a Tupac greatest hits I would be
down for it right Thank You Sony that
got music for four hours exactly well no
it's only one CD they said but in terms
of guys that I would want in their first
thought I want no fat offensive lineman
so I was Josh a dozen Josh Rosen is
going to be in the elevator we're gonna
have really good conversations could be
all over the place I also thought about
having Jalen Ramsey it's gonna crack
jokes the whole time I don't need all
smart people right like I think Josh
Rosen - Jalen Ramsey would be really fun
i-ight Jalen actually went in my brain -
and then I also I'm not gonna go cool
like I'm not gonna go Alvin Kamara I'm
not gonna go corny with Russell Wilson
I'm not gonna go Jimmy like if I had
like a Richard Sherman Jalen Ramsay Josh
Rosen me listening to snoop that was
really no good answer no there's not
they're all good answers that's what we
give you here no I don't really I
deliberately really tried to cancel out
big alignment no Marine rules an effect
of that one damn yeah like Cam Newton
would be cool but like you're taking up
too much room pal hit you baby you two
up dare you be that big yeah let me get
Darren Sproles Theo Riddick and like a
little carry kills thing you can spread
out a little guy on the Chargers Rico
[Music]
fumbled at the end of the game yeah I
know I can't leave Oliver no close
wasn't Oliver no not Melvin Gordon and
his biceps can you look somebody up and
do something yeah I'm doing it hold on
and Ezekiel
closed its slot legs are too big
Austin Eckler I don't think that's it
damn did you get cut or you talk about
number 43 yes it was Oliver I think
that's the end of the podcast left car
you want to wrap this thing up Andre
Williams no I wasn't whomever it was
alright guys that was a lot of fun I
really enjoyed it Josh thank you so much
anytime Adam for organize I'm happy to
do it guys we will be back on Wednesday
I think we're still trying to figure it
out we do gotta figure that Mabel do
another mailbag next week we have we
have another Steve we have a Steve Nash
event in New York where he's like doing
a big soccer event to help host that's
right
but I'm gonna share something too I want
you guys to get excited coming up
few months Sims and I are not only gonna
have the podcast where we review the
games and we preview the games and do
what we've always done but we're
developing a bigger show that's gonna
come out on Wednesdays during this
season it's gonna be the podcast put on
video like you know like a real studio
in a set and it's gonna be us it's gonna
be real it's gonna be fun it's gonna be
a good time so I just want you guys to
know that we're doing a lot of meetings
for that right now and we're really
really excited we're excited to share
that with you and I figure the mailbag
episode was a good place to share that
so for Simms he's out homies fendron
good night everybody keep tweeting at
Sims aleph go share go on iTunes leave
us that five star review we appreciate
it
I am the lef koe man and we will holla
holla holla hope your weekend was great
then we will talk to you very soon peace
[Music]